regarde là les deux plus beaux l'after
avec nous ce soir or là nous ont fait
connaissance lors de la sortie de votre
livre miettes dans une interview lors
d'une émission de télévision qui
s'appelle ça s'en va et ça revient
d'ailleurs je dois dire à mes amis
téléspectateurs que lundi soir une à une
avec les inconnus qui est pas piquée des
hannetons en à raconter votre vie votre
enfance douloureuse et on m'a beaucoup
reproché ma gentillesse avec vous avez
souvent mais c'est faux alors j'en
profite pour dire que je regrette pas du
tout ma gentillesse avec loana j'ai
beaucoup de compassion pour votre
histoire et je maintiens tout ce que
j'ai dit ce soir là tout ce que j'ai
fait ce soir et ça sera à refaire je
referais exactement la même chose merci
beaucoup voilà
je pense que ce soit des gens comme vous
qui trouvez reculé en tous les cas alors
il s'est bien vendu votre livre très
bien oui combien peu à peu près cent
mille exemples c'est beaucoup dire c'est
bien donc l'éditeur a récupéré la valoir
d'un million de francs qui vous avez
versé oui en principe on est content
mais oui comment va votre mère très très
bien voilà il n'ya pas longtemps yvette
va bien il va te battrais parce que
toute la famille maintenant oui c'est
vrai votre père les par bull n'ont
toujours pas bien marché donc un coup de
fil ça va s'arranger là tu sais mais
c'est parce qu'ils ont les faire en ce
moment ouais c'est le poème de pertes ou
les deux là bas on a un peu la veille
enfin voiture et cela même mais un
niveau famille où on n'a pas eu beaucoup
de chance je suis tramway comment vous
est venue dans l'émission beaucoup de
gens étaient choqués par le fait que
vous soyez pas retourner voir votre
fille mindy
immédiatement après le loft est-ce que
depuis vous et avait non je suis partout
d'avoir ma fille est par contre sans
contact et je sais qu'elles valent très
très très bien non pour vous voulez pas
la voir il fallait vraiment pas qu'on
sache où aller mais bientôt de ça ça va
s'arranger bien à part ça ça va bien
maintenant avec argent du loft vous
achetez un trois pièces à paris oui vous
emménagez en décembre décembre ni
décembre je le dis à nos amis je voulait
pendre la crémaillère si
dans le 16ème
rue de la pompe
visé dans le mille un parent c'est à
beaucoup de presse oui des problèmes
avec la presse toujours loana non non
non
je pense pas qu'ils aient vraiment
maintien en fait à trouver un scandale
jusque là je reste
entrevue disais je suis une info man
quand je suis amoureuse mais quand vous
n'êtes pas amoureux souvent toute façon
ça fait pas à conséquence je pense
qu'alors on l'est tous en fait quand on
goûte tomber
non ça va être dur à faire beaucoup mais
recevant m quand on rencontre quelqu'un
qu'on aime bien sûr en revanche c'est la
très bonne article dans le magazine
photo est un magazine très prestigieux
après mondino et bettina rheims ce coup
ci c'est de marcher rien qui vous a fait
des photos à new york alors demarchelier
qui était un grand photographe vous a
demandé de poser nue loana sans déconner
me regarde ce que j'ai
fait pour lui donc c'est ça vous avez
refusé de le faire c'est refuser mais de
le faire j'ai pas non ça ça me fait de
me préparer je pense pas que j'aurais
été à l'aise donc c'est pas la peine il
me l'a pas raciste et il m'a proposé
j'ai dit que je me sentirai palais
gilles hâlais ce coin voulait préserver
votre intimité une certaine petite
partie oui merci pour pour votre homme
pour mon âme je vais vous allez bientôt
rencontrer mais j'espère verra bien
brigitte que la première fois que vous
faites l'amour avec quelqu'un qui est
obligé d'être dans le noir très pudique
loi nâ 1 c'est vrai oui un petit peu
mais je sais pas
et ça complètement dans l'est la
première fois c'est vrai que dans là
vous étiez en string et topless assez
souvent non non je veux dire quand on se
changeait forcément bien passé un stade
où on est tous le monde pour changer ça
vous gênez pas dans le loft mais j'étais
pas là entre rentrer comme ça ça sera
doux j'étais tout nu et bien sûr mais
bon quand je me déshabille et je me
déshabiller sur mon lit loana on va
parler de votre on va parler de votre
calendrier ce qui vient qu'un
monsieur
non attendez d'affilée autre chose ma
fille à autre chose c'est ça
déloyale ces délais
c'est le calendrier alors racontez nous
ce calendrier loi n'a alors le
calendrier loana ça a été une
proposition qui m'a été fait et l
ambition vouloir mettre les mois dans
l'ordre alors comment c'est quand même
assez logique est partie l'idée quand
comment
non mais on m'a proposé de faire un
calendrier est ce que la chose que j'ai
trouvé très belle et je parte c'est bien
photo voilà ce sont de belles photos
mais pudique ou pas bah oui
loana le premier disque de loana le
premier calendrier de loana est le
premier baffie de loana
et quand le tourbillon s'arrête quand
vient le soir
seul avec son chien necker
mais qu'elle s'appelle n'est qu'après un
nom d'hôpital pour un chien mais je
savais pas à l'époque c'était le chien
de ma tante quand j'étais tout petit
c'est énorme ce qui m'impressionnait et
j'ai voulu en mettre leur match le
prénom sont donc voilà seul le soin avec
son chien mesquer vous redevenez la
loana d'avant mais je pense bien si
c'est elle qui commande une grosse pizza
temps en temps j'aime bien faire foi
mais bien sûr vous êtes seul le soir
chez vous et qu'il grosse pizza et de
vidéos ça n'arrive pas tout le temps
mais j'aime bien oui c'est une grosse et
regarder quelques films aussi je suis
tout seul chez moi le soir avec les
fours auspices
c'est ridicule ça voilà donc le alain
coeur à prendre et encore
brown dès maintenant à tous genres voilà
pour énoncer un appel non non non non
mais c'est quoi tes centres d'intérêts
thème bien courir ni au ralenti sur la
plage non pas trop ces freins de quoi
les promenades en forêt le cinéma les
pizzas voilà voilà la petite lou c'est
important pour les gens vous le faites
si bien
ouais j'ai pas suivi parce que j'ai tout
le monde dans le rang
cherchait un mec
ou qu'ils aimeraient profiter à leurs
femmes pour le manger quoi me dit votre
type dit un acteur qu'on voit un peu à
quoi ça ressemble quand un acteur
la terre comme ça à bruce willis à moi
je
le cuir est à venir loana interview
expliqué à ma fille
loana si votre petite fille qui parle
par ma bouche
comme dans l'exorciste
dit maman il est où papa papa n'a pas
voulu de toi
dis maman c'est qu'ils jean-edouard
je te montre america 7 y compris
dis maman tu m'aimes bien suivi
oui j'aime beaucoup et baffie tulle aime
bien jusque là ça va on verra plus tard
et hardy sont très sains allumeuse
dis maman comment on fait les bébés
espère un petit peu plus tard quand on a
grandi ah bon tu m'expliqueras louana
dis maman pourquoi le monsieur qui vient
des fois la maison il tombera sur la
bouche
ah
parce que parce qu'il aime beaucoup
pourquoi ne voit plus tout le temps à la
télé parce que je préfère m'occuper de
toi m'a
dit maman
le monsieur qui est embrasse tout le
temps sur la bouche il a fait la même
chose à la baby sitter
sébine dit là bas je
dis maman on va rester toujours ensemble
maintenant oui bien sûr
je t'aime c'est une chanson spécialement
pour moi j'avais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu